[موسيقى]
مساء الخير دايما في اهتمام كبير جدا بطرق
الملاحه البحريه وخصوصا تلك التي تنافس
قناه السويس او غيرها من الممرات البحريه
المهمه في
العالم وفي السنوات الاخيره ار الحديث عن
طرق ملاحيه بحريه جديده سوف تغير خريطه
التجاره العالميه لكن تحديدا منذ ان بدات
حرب غزه وبدايه من 7 اكتوبر تجدد الحديث
عن
ممر ملاحي بعينه وهو ما يسمى بقناه بن
جوريون هذا الممر بيقول من يتحدث عنه انه
سوف يكون منافسا جديدا لقناه السويس وسوف
يغير ايضا خريطه التجاره العالميه باكمل
ما هو هذا المشروع ولماذا ار عنه الحديث
مؤخرا وما هي المشاريع الملاحيه البحريه
الاهم في العالم المنافسه لقناه السويس عن
كل هذه الموضوعات انا بستيف اليوم واحد من
اهم خبراء
التجاره البحريه في مصر والعالم العربي
المهندس وائل الدور عضو مجلس اداره قناه
السويس السابق اهلا وسهلا باشمهندس اهلا
بيك يا سيد باشا اتمنى تكون في احسن حال
وفي احسن صحه الحمد لله الحمد لله هل
استاذن حضرتك ان احنا نبدا ب ما هي قناه
بن جوريون ثم لماذا ثار عنها الحديث مؤخرا
قويي قناه بن جوريوم فكره قديمه لربط
البحر الاحمر بالبحر الابيض كان بيقابلها
عقبات لان هناك تدريس على الارض توصل فرق
الارتفاعات
380 متر لانها بيضطر يمشي في ودي عربه
والجبال دي من الخليج العقبه اه الى حيفه
اه فال التكلفه بتاعتها مرعبه وكذلك
امكانيات التنفيذ لدرجه ان امريكا في سنه
63 اقترحت انها تستخدم قنابل نوويه
الصغيره لتفتيت هذه الجبال والمساعده في
الحفر انما نتيجه التكنولوجي ما كانش ناضج
في اشاعات وفي
كذا صرف النظر عن
هذا النهارده رجع الكلام بعد حرب
غزه على قناه بنجوري قال لك لا احنا مش
هنمشي في الطريق
البعيده احنا هنحتل غزه وتبقى اسرائيليه
وبالتالي نقدر نوصل من العقب قوى الى غزه
على البحر الابيض دي اقصر واسهل واقل في
التكاليف اه دي الفكره وليه النهارده بهذه
الكلام
بيتردد اذا الكلام اللي بيتردد عن كلام عن
قناه بن جوريون ماهواش كلام عشوائي يعني
كلام له اسس لا اسس من قديم الزمان انما
كان بيقف عقبات التكنولوجي والتكلفه
العاليه وفي دي عند قناه السويس اقصر وما
تقدرش تنافس معاها لان تكلفتها هتبقى
عاليه جدا انا عاوز استاذن حضرتك واذكر
المشاهدين هو وارجو ان تصحح ني يعني لما
ثار الكلام بالحاح بين الاسرائيليين
والامريكان عن حفر قناه بديله كان في اوجه
الصراع
العربي العربي الاسرائيلي ووجود جمال عبد
الناصر ووضع العقبات احيانا لمرور السفن
الاسرائيليه او غيرها في قناه السويس وهذا
لم يعد قائما الان لا برض قائم بمعنى ايه
في سنه 21 لما السفينه الحاويات العملاقه
ايفر جيبن
قفلت القناه
واستعرضت العالم كله اتاثر وخطوط
الامدادات صبلاي تشين فعرفوا اهميه قناه
السويس وازاي الطريق واحد ده ممكن يربك
العالم ويسبب خسائر كانت بتوصل 9.6 من
مليار دولار يوميا فمن هنا بيوريك اهميه
قناه السويس قد ايه واخد بالك
فابتدع في طرق كثيره بقى بديله عنها
اهمها وهو ده اللي هيبقى مؤثر رئيسي على
قناه السويس طريق القطب الشمالي نتيجه
ذوبان الجليد في المحيط المتجمد الشمالي
هيتفتح للملاحه لطول السنه واخد بالك بعد
بعد
2050 ده اكتر طريق بيهدد قناه السويس
ويهدد قناه بن جورن اذا عملوها واي قناه
يعني بعد حوالي 25 سنه بعد 25 سنه
دي المؤثر الرئيس طب هل ممكن توضح لنا
يعني ليه بعد 25 سنه من المتوقع ان يصبح
هذا الطريق بهذه الفاعليه
تمام الجليد في القطب الشمالي بينح السر
كل 10 سنين بينخ فض بمقدار 12.5
في وبعدين مش بس كده الجليد ده انواع كان
في فتره الستينات والسبعينات في حاجه
بنسميها جليد السنوات
المتعدده يعني ايه السنوات المعدد يعني
بيجي
الصيف الجديد بيدوب لو لو ما دبش كله
هيفضل شويه منه يجي عليه السنه الجايه
يبقى جليد السنه الثانيه ده بيزداد سمك
وصلابه لما يجي الثالثه والرابعه وخامسه
يبقى عمليه الابحار فيه ما تقدرش ويه يشق
جسم المركب
هذا التركيبه بتاعه الجليد النهارده في
القطب الشمالي في الوقت اللي احنا بنتكلم
فيه معظم الجليد اللي موجود في القطب
الشمالي نقدر
نقول 90 او 92% جليد السنه الاولى اللي هو
ممكن الملاحه فيه وسمكه لا يتجاوز 2 متر
السنوات المتعدده قلت خالص وفي اماكن
محدده فمع مرور الزمن هتقل اكتر فبالتالي
قناه القطب الشمالي هيبقى ممكن الملاحه
فيه على طول السنه ومش بس كده احنا دلوقتي
بمشي في طريق القطب الشمالي في المياه
الساحليه بتاعه روسيا فمين بيتحكم فيه
روسيا لما يدوب بقى المحيط ده المتجمد
همشي في عادي البحار لا هدفع فلوس ولا
روسيا ولا غيرها تتحكم فيها فدي الخطوره
اللي فيها عشان كده بنقول بعد 2049 معنى
كده ان في معادلات رياضيه حسبها العلماء
وجدوا ان معدل ذوبان الجليد بحلول 49 او
50 يعني عام سنه 50 2050 هتكون الظروف
المناخيه قد اتاحت
الملاحه المصوره طوال السنه اه في الحاله
ده هياثر المسافه ما بين شرق العالم وغربه
بالظبط كده عن نفس المسافه اللي بيقطعها
عن طريق قناه السويس بنسبه قد ايه 40%
يعني انا لو بحتاج مثلا في قناه السويس
100 اه كيلو الطريق ده يبقى 40 كيلو يبقى
60 كيلو لان هو يختصر 40 60 ب 60 كيلو طيب
عظيم هل ده نفترض ان هذا الطريق اللي احنا
بنتكلم عن سنوات قليله تمام نفترض انه هذا
المخطط صار على هذا النحو اللي هو مبني
على افتراض انه التغير المناخي سوف يسير
بنفس الوتيره هل هيكون الطريق الشمالي ده
افضل لكل دول العالم من قناه السويس ولا
هيكون افضل لدول ودول ثانيه سوف تظل بحكم
موقع الجغرافي تفضل قناه السويس هيفضل دول
معينه هتفضل هذا الطريق للوفره اللي
بتوفره ودول ثانيه هتفضل قناه السويس
للوفره اللي بتوفره لها في نقطه تعادل
لهذا الطريق عند تايلاند
تايلاند شرق تايلاند يبقى طريق القطب
الشمالي دول هتختار القطب الشمالي ا غرب
تايلاند دول هتختار قناه السويس نجد منها
دوله طلعه طلعه جامده جدا اه طبعا الهند
الهند الهند دي هتبقى ثالث اص اصاد عالمي
في سنه 20 50
والنهارده امريكا والدول الغربيه بتدفع
فيها لتحتل مكانه الصين كمصنع للعالم
وعشان كده عملوا المبادره بتاعه الممر
الند الخليج اسرائيل اوروبا فكل واحد
بيدور ايه
مصلحته كل واحد بيدور ايه مصلحته واد بالك
وانت كمان لازم تدور ايه مصلحتك طيب ما
اتكلم على مصلحتك بالنسبه طبعا كل دوله
بتدور على مصالحها اذا تحدثنا عن طريق
الممر الاقتصادي اللي هو بيربط الهند بدول
الخليج
ثم اوروبا عبر اسرائيل الطريق ده اللي هو
اعلن عنه من عده شهور لكن بيدرسوه من فتره
طويله هل ده هيربط دول الخليج الهند ودول
الخليج باوروبا عن طريق اسرائيل بريا ام
بحريا بحريا يب قلب عن قر بن جوريون طيب
في جزء ما كانش سات ماقلنا ما كانش فيه
بيتكلموا
على هو في جزء بحري ان انا هنقل من الهند
لدول الخليج لات مواني في الامارات
ومئين في السعوديه بعد كده عن طريق شبكه
جصور بريه وسك حديد بري بقى هيقوم داخل
على
الاردن ثم اسرائيل ومن
اسرائيل الى اوروبا بحري تاني ده الفكره
دي كانت الفكره طب هل الممر ده هو طبعا ده
فكرته قديمه ولا جديده يا
باشمهندس فكرته جديده لان لما الصين اعلنت
مبادره الطوق والطريق 2013 2013 ازعجك
امريكا جدا و قت تفكر ازاي تطلع بمبادره
ضدها وتسحب البساط من تحتها فتوصلوا لهذا
الطريق مع الدول الغربيه واخد بال سيادتك
فمن هنا جت الدفع اللي بتدفعه امريكا
والدول الغربيه لانجاح هذا الطريق عشان
تموت خطه الصين والطوق والطريق انا طبعا
هسال حضرتك عن خطه الصين لكن هل تاذ لي ان
انا اوضح حاجه وحضرتك صحح لي ان كنت مخطئ
انه هذا المشروع اللي هو الممر الاقتصادي
هو مرتبط بتصور سياسي انه يبقى في تحالف
ا ادماج لاسرائيل لدول المنطقه ومعاهم
طبعا الهند اللي تحسنت علاقتها باسرائيل
كثيرا رغم البروده في العلاقات تاريخيا
بين اسرائيل والهند ومع تحسن المناخ
السياسي يبتدي يمر المشروع الممر
الاقتصادي اللي هيربط اسرائيل بدول كانت
علاقتها تاريخيا سيئه باسرائيل دول الخليج
والهند لكن
كمان المشروع ده بيفتروا العلاقات
الخليجيه سوف تسمح بذلك وكان احد اهم
دعائم هذه الفكره انه يحصل عمليه التطبيع
بين السعوديه واسرائيل تمام
بعد طوفان الاقصى وحرب غزه وتوتر العلاقات
بين الدول العربيه واسرائيل ربما يتجمد
هذا المشروع على الاقل لفتره طويله في
المدى المنظور اعتقد لو
هيتجمعوا
خد بال
سيادتك امريكا والغرب بصفه عامه همها ان
اللي يقود هذه المنطقه هي اسرائيل فعاوزه
تدمجها في هذا الكيان بتاع الشرق الاوسط
وتقوده عشان امريكا تتفرغ لم محاره الصين
ده الفكره وبالتالي بترجح انه بعد ان
انتهت الامور هتعود نفس طيب احنا لما
بنتكلم على مشروع الحزام والطريق واحنا
اتكلمنا عنه في القناه قبل كده اذا تحدثنا
عن احد اهم دوافع الصين من مشروع الحزام
الطريق اللي هي عباره عن طرق تجاريه بتربط
الصين بالعالم تمام جوهر المشروع ده اهم
اهداف الصين منه ايه
الصين اقتصادها مبني على التجاره هي مصنع
العالم 80% من التجاره بتاعتها بتمر في
مضيق ملقا اللي هو عند
سنغافوره هي خايفه ان لو هذا المضيق اغلق
اتخنقت طبعا فبدور على طرق اخرى بديله
فنجد مثلا انها دورت على هتعمل قناه في ن
كراجو اكبر كتير من قناه بانما واخد بالك
وبدون اهوس وتستطيع استقبال السفن الكبيره
جدا
ومولت ب 50 مليار دولار هذا المشروع سنه
2014 ده قريب ثم امريكا بدات تزاول ضغوط
على ن كراجو ان ده هياثر على البيئه ومش
البيئه والكلام ده ووقف اس ده واقف لفتره
معينه انما ان عاجلا او اجلا
نفس فدي احد الطرق اللي بتفكر فيها كذلك
هتمو قناه في ك رجوه باختصار اذا يعني
نفذت هتبقى مفيده للصين من حيث ايه ا
بتسهل تجارتها مع دول امريكا الشماليه
واحد بالك لان كلنا نم مع مع دول امريكا
الشماليه يعني الولايات المتحده ك
ومكسيك تمام ا نجد انه قناه بنا ما لها
سعه محدوده ورغم التوسعات اللي عملت اللي
حصلت لغايه
2017 برده ما تستقبل كل انواع السفن يعني
اقصى سفينه
حاويات
12500 نو الاكبر من كده بيعدي في قناه
السويس بعد كده هيبقى هيعدي في قناه ن
كراكو ف فتسحب من قناه بانما ومن قناه
السويس من قناه السويس لان قناه السويس
مشتركه مع قناه بانما في البضايع اللي
بتروح الساحل الشرقي لامريكا اه لما تيجي
تبص كده بتجد ان ايه قناه بنا عشان البضاع
جايه من الصين
تروح الساحل الشرقي اللي هي نيويورك ونيو
جيرسي والمواني الشرقيه دي كلها بتحتاج 26
يوم قناه السويس تحتاج 28 يوم يعني فرق
يومين واخد لصالح بنمه لصالح بنمه انما
الاحجام الكبيره واقتصاديات الحجم لصالح
قناه السويس تيجي برضو نجد ان الجسر البري
اللي بيربط شرق امريكا
بغربها ده برض بيسحب جزء كبير من التجاره
وياخد ست ايام عشان تين البضاع من الساحل
الغربي للساحل
الشالي لما تشتغل قناه ك كراجو ما قعدش
فيه سقف معين لاحجام السفن وما فيش اهوس
وتقدر تستوعب كل انواع الس طبعا حضرتك
ممكن لو توضح لنا ببساطه الاهوسه فكرتها
ايه الاهوسه لما اجي انا اعمل
القناه مش كلها في مستوى البحر اه فبضطر
اعمل احواض ادخل المراكب فيها واضخ فيها
ميه واقوم رافع على المستوى وانقلها لهوس
اني لمستوى اعلى الى ان يوصل لمستوى سطح
البحر سطح البحر ولما تيجي تنزل نفس
الكلام بالتدريج عظيم جدا عظيم جدا اذا
مشروع نيكارجوا اللي هو جزء من مشروع
الحزام والطريق كان احد مشاريع الصين
لتنويع طرق التجاره لها في
الاك كذلك في مشروع في جنوب تايلاند اسمها
قناه كارا كارا دي طولها 120 كيلو
وبتوفر يومين بتوفر 1200 كيلو للتجاره
اللي طالعه من الصين راح الغرب فدي لصالح
وهي هتمون ب 30 مليار
دولار يعني ال 120 كيلو ب 30 مليار دولار
فلما تيجي تبص
لقناه بن جوريوم اللي اتكلمنا عليها في
الاول هتبقى تقريبا
290 او 300 كيلو شوف هتبقى تكلفتها ايه
واخد بالك يعني تقريبا كده لو يعني
هتعدي
ال اه هتعدي ال 50 مليار دولار في طريق
غزه انما
الطرق الصعبه الثانيه تفك كده بكتير
جدا هل في طرق تانيه تحب تشير اليها شغله
الناس او الصين بتسعى اليها في الوقت
الحالي علشان تهرب من مضيق ملقا ا سيادتك
طبعا الصين اطلقت مبادره الطوق والطريق
فعملت شبكه طرق بتحزم العالم كله عشان
تضمن تجارتها توصل من الصين الى
اوروبا كذلك في الطريق البحري بتاعها كذلك
ضخه استثمارات ايه طريق البحري بتاعها
اللي هو بيطلع من الصين بحريا يروح على
مثلا
كولومبو يخش بعد كده على قناه السويس ثم
يطلع على اوروبا والكلام ده كذلك ضخت
استثمارات ضخمه جدا في البنيه الاساسيه
للقطب الشمالي في اه عشان ده مستفيده منه
واخد بالك لان احنا لازم نعرف ان
25% من مخزون العالم الذي لم يكتشف من
البترول والغاز موجود في القطب الش
فهتبقى الحرب الجايه كلها على مصادر
البترول والغاز في القطب الشمالي تجاز
انها دخلت ايه مساهمه كبيره جدا في محطه
الاساله اللي في القطب الشمالي ياميل
واحد روسيا اه ودخلت كمان معاها فرنسا في
التموين ف واخد بالك كذلك المحطه الثانيه
القطب الشمالي اثنين داخله نسبه مساهمه
جدا اذا هي اللي بتساعد ان طريق القطب
الشمالي يستكمل البنيه الاساسيه
و تتغلب على العقبات اللي بتقابل الملاحه
في هذا الطريق انا استاذنك اوضح حاجه
بسيطه للمتابعين واسال حضرتك سؤال طبعا
القصه كلها فيما يتعلق بالصين وارجو
انه المهندس وائل يعني صحح لي انه الصين ك
لها طبعا بلد اقتصاد ضخم جدا ا وهي رقم
واحد في التجاره العالميه وبتعتمد بشكل
اساسي على التصدير وعلشان تصدر منتجات
نهائيه لازم تستقبل مواد خام تمام شريان
الاساس اللي بتستقبل منه المواد الخام
واللي بترسل منه بضائعها
والبحر وهناك مديق ملقى اللي تحدثنا عنه
في حلقات سابقه هذا المضيق بيمر منه نصيب
الاسد من واردتها وصادرت 80% 80% اذا تعطل
هذا المضيق لاي اسباب اتخنقت الصين اتخنقت
الصين فهي ولذلك سميت بسماه الصينيين بمل
ديلمه او يعني ماسات او معضله مضيق ملقا
فاحد يعني احد دوافع الصين لمشروع الحزام
والطريق هي خلق طرق بديله تغنيها عن هذا
الطريق طيب هذا للتوضيح يعني سؤال سؤال يا
باشمهندس احنا في المنطقه هنا بنسمع عن
طرق ا يعني مش قادرين نحطها في سياقها
العام يعني مثلا اذا بدانا بالعراق العراق
عنده مشروع طموح قديم اللي هو مشروع الفو
الكبير ما هو هذا المشروع ماذا يستفيد منه
العراق كيف يؤثر على باقي طرق
الملاحه مشروع الفاو الكبير هو بينشا
ميناء الفاو ده يعتبر اكبر ميناء في شرق
اسيا الطاقه بتاعته 100 مليون طن سنويا اه
يستطيع تداول 27 مليون حاويه عند استكماله
يعني اكبر كتير من جبل علي والكلام ده
والفكره مبنيه ان ايه التجاره هتجي لك من
الصين وجنوب شرق اسيا الى ميناء الفاو ثم
عن طريق جسور بريه وسكك حديديه هتخش بعد
كده على تر ثم اوروبا اذا ده ينعش التجاره
بتاع العراق ويخليها
تجتذب حصه كبيره من التجاره العالميه
بجانب اللوجستيات
واقتصاديات القيمه المضافه اللي هتتم على
هذه التجاره فده هينقل نقله كبيره جدا وده
امل العراق فيه هو المرحله الاولى فيه
هتشتغل السنه الجايه اللي هي 20 24 هم
عملوا اكبر حاجز امواج في العالم كاسر
امواج بطول 14 ص كيلو متر واللي عملته لهم
كوريا الجنوبيه شركه دايو واخد بالك وده
يعتبر من المشاريع الضخمه جدا فده في صالح
العراق كتير جدا واقتصاد العراق وفي نفس
الوقت هيبقى ممر للطاقه العراق عارفين
انها بتنتج البترول والكلام ده فكل دوله
بتفكر ازاي تستفيد من موقعها في النقل
البحري هل هذا المشروع يؤثر على اي من
المشروعات القائمه او التي يمكن ا او التي
يتم دراستها يعني في مشاريع قائمه زي قناه
السويس وفي مشاريع بتفكر فيها ايران
وبتفكر فيها روسيا بلا شك بصر يعني لما
تيجي تلاقي مثلا ايه المشروع بتاع الهند
روسيا الممر من الشمال للجنوب طيب ما هو
المشروع ده هياخد جزء كبير من تجارته اذا
هياثر واخد بالك الفكره الاساسيه احنا
عندنا كعكه كل واحد عاوز ياخد حته من
الكعكه دي اللي بيفكر صح ايه هي الكعكه
اللي هي التجاره العالميه التجاره
العالميه والخدمات اه يعني التجاره
العالميه في سنه 22 كانت ب 25 ترليون
دولار اه وكانت الخدمات ب 6.7 من ترليون
دولار اه واخد بالك فكل واحد عاوز يزود
نصيبه من هذه الكعكه وتتزايد
سانوي دي الفكره ايه اهم المشروعات احنا
سمعنا ان ايران يعني نشطه في مجموعه من
المشروعات اطرافها تحديدا الهند وروسيا
يعني داخلين في عده مشروعات ايه اهم مشروع
الايران بتفكر فيه ويخدم مين ويضر
مين اللي هو بتفكر فيه اللي هو الممر بتاع
الهند ا ايران روسيا اوروبا روس اوروبا ده
غير الطريق الشمالي طبعا غير طريق القطب
الشمالي ده غيره اه ده بيخدم ايران بياثر
على العراق بياثر بلا شك برض لو اشتغل صح
هيسحب جزء من التجاره العبره لقناه السويس
ل قناه السيس شغاله على التجاره المنوله
بين التكتلات اوروبا
واسيا اسيا وامريكا الساحل الشرقي فكل ده
بيتاثر
ا ومشروع الفو الكبير يؤثر على هذا
المشروع بلا شك ويؤثر سلبا برضو جزئيا على
قناه السويس ويؤثر على قناه بن جورين ان
تم تمام مضبوط كده تمام فهي مشروعات
متضربه ومتناقض تمام كده مظبوط تمام كده
احنا كنا دا داما بنسمع بقى بالاضافه
للمشروعات البحريه ايضا طرق بريه واسرائيل
كانت في القلب من هذه المشروعات خليني
اسال حضرتك السؤال الاول قبل ما اسالك على
الطرق البريه هي اسرائيل عندها فعلا بتخطط
لمشروعات ا تغير بها المنطقه بحيث ان هي
تبقى في قلب هذه المنطقه من العالم بلا شك
عندها هذه المشروعات ا مثلا نجد عندها خط
السكه الحديد اللي بيربط ايلات
ب عسقلان بعسقلان او بحيفا واخد بال
سيادتك ده تكلفته خمسه مليار وده متمون من
ميزانيه الطوق والطريق بتاع الصين واخد
بالك وده ابتدوا في سنه
بيعمل
قناه طولها 10 كيلو في الاراضي
الاسرائيليه من ايلات لان ميناء ايلات
الواجهه بتا
بتاعته محدوده على البحر الاحمر فهو دخل
بقناه وبعدين كبر المينا وعامل مراكز
لوجستيه وانشطه قيمه مضافه ثم ينقل بعد
كده بسكه حديد طولها 300 كيلو سريعه الى
البحر الابيض ده احد الطرق ده يخدم ايه
بقى يخدم الطرق اللي جايه من الدول الخلي
يعني هو في بيخدم حاجتين تج سيادتك يمكن
60 او
63% من تجاره اسرائيل مع دول من اسيا فاذا
معظم تجارتها بجلها من الجنوب كانت ايه
بتضطر ايه تعبر قناه السويس وتدفع رسوم
عشان تروح ل مواني البحر الابيض لان ميناء
ايلات محدود الواجهه فبالتالي هي عاوزه
توفر الفلوس اللي بتدفعها لقناه السويس
فعملت قناه ملاحيه ودخلت بالمينا جوه
وربطت سكه حديد اه وربطت سكه حديد يربط
بين ايلات والبحر الابيض ده احد مشاريعها
المشاريع الثانيه زي ما شفنا محور الممر
التجاري الهند الشرق الاوسط اسرائيل
امريكا دي عشان ايه تندمج في اقتصاد
المنطقه وتبقى ليدين في الخدمات
واللوجستيات وال بس مش هي المشروع ده
مرتبط برض بمشروع اللي هو السكه الحديد
ولا كله مربوط بسكه حديد المشروع
الاسرائيلي الحقيقي حضرتك خبير احنا بنسمع
كلام كتير اللي ممكن يمثل فعلا نقله كبيره
لاسرائيل ويضر بالمشروعات الاخرى البديله
وعلى راسها قناه السويس اي
مشروع اللي هو اندماج اسرائيل مع دول
الخليج واخد بالك ونقل
بضايع الخليج كلها عن طريق اسرائيل
بضاي الطاقه البترول الغاز والبضائع
العاديه ده بلا شك هياثر بشده على قناه
السويس والمشروع ده هيعتمد على طرق سكه
حديديه في البدايه سكه حديد وبري سكه حديد
جزء بحري لغايه المواني بتاع الامارات في
السعوديه ثم سكك حديد وطرق بريه ثم بحري
ثاني من اسرائيل لاار حضرتك بتتكلم على
الخط كله اللي هو الممر الاقتصادي يعني ان
تاتي البضائع من الهند وغير تمام عن طريق
البحر ثم يمر بريا وسكك حديديه الى
اسرائيل ومنه الى هذا هو اخطر مشروع اه ده
ياثر بلا شك طيب بما ان احنا اتكلمنا عن
القصه ديت يعني احنا دايما قناه السويس مش
شان مصري بس هي شان مصري وشان دولي ايه
اهم الاعتبارات باختصار شديد جدا التي
تؤثر سلبا او ايجابا على قناه السويس بحيث
ان هي لا تفقد اهميتها كش شريان ملاحيه
بالمناسبه اهم شريان ملاحي في العالم ولا
ثاني اهم ثاني بعد بعد المضيق مق وتب
سيادتك احنا بس قناه السويس بيعبر منها
12% من الملاحه العالميه من التجاره
العالميه بيعبر منها 30% من الحاويات
المتبادله في العالم
ا 10% من البترول ومنتجاته 88% من الغاز
المثال
14.5% من الاسمده
14.6% من تجاره الحبوب فيوريل لك اهميه
قناه السويس
ازاي اللي بياثر في قناه السويس مجموعه من
العوامل نمسك اول حاجه البنيه التحتيه
لقناه السويس بمعنى الغاطس بتاعها المقطع
المائي السفن اللي مسموح بها حمولتها قد
ايه كذلك الاير درافت من سطح البحر لكبر
السلام
68 متر دي كلها محددات للسفن اللي
بتبر اقصى يعني دي بتضع قيود على اقصى حجم
للسفن اللي ممكن تع تمام وهقول
لكاني ان في سنه 20 50 حجم التجاره لو ل
مشينا بالمعدلات ديت هتوصل
3500 3500 مليون طن سنه
2050 احنا النهارده بيعدي 1420 يعني اكتر
من الضعف فانت لازم هتعمل عالميا في كل
الممرات لا اللي بيعب قناه السويس سنه 20
50 اه انت لازم هتعمل ازدواج للقناه عشان
تحافظ على حصتك دي و تعمل خطوط لنقل
الطاقه وكبلات
لنقل المعلومات والكلام دوت كل دي
بنيه انت محتاجها بجانب ان في 20 يعني
ابتدت تظهر النوعيات من السفن زيتيه
القياده 20 سنه 20 نعم في سنه 20 من ثلاث
سنين يعني انت قلت في سنه 20 ولا في 2050
2050 2050 زاتيه القياده دي موجوده حاليا
واخد بال سيادتك بس هتنتشر بقى واخد بالك
فاذا انت هتتعامل معه يبقى لازم عندك شبكه
الاعمار الصناعيه مشترك
فيها نظم الارشاد بتاعتك والش مننت يبقى
عليها سنسور يستطيع انه يتحكم ويدي اشارات
والكلام ده دي كلها عمليه خطيره جدا انا
عاوز اختم بسؤال واستاذن نستانف في حلقات
اخرى مشروع محور قناه السويس احنا طبعا
ابتهج انا به جدا لما اعلن عنه في 2014
و205 انا ماعرفش الى اي يعني باي درجه
يسير الان لانه قد يكون متاثرا بالازمه
الاقتصاديه هل يسير بوتيره معقوله ولا
متباطئ وماذا يمكن ان يضيف اذا سار بوتيره
سريعه ستك مشروع قناه السويس مش بدا في
2014 بدا في سنه 844 محور قناه السويس اه
ده
اليابان ادتنا منحه وقالت يا جماعه خلي
بالكم ان هونج كونج هتروح الصين سنه 90
واحنا شايفين ان السويس ممكن تبقى بديل
لهونج كونج وادت منحه خططت منطقه شمال غرب
خليج السويس عشان تبقى بديل لهونج كونج
وما عملناش حاجه بعد كده جه محور قناه
السويس من 2014 وكذا مش ماشي بالخطوات
المامول منها لا لان ده هو طوق النجاه
لمصر كلها اللي بيجيلك من رسوم العبور لا
يتجاوز 5% من اللي انت المفروض يجيلك من
موقعك ولو فعلت محور قناه السويس يقدر
يجيلك اكتر من 200 مليار دولار اذا انت مع
كنس لازم تدي اهتمام شديد واولو مطلقه
لهذا اكتر من اي مشروع اني من اللي انت
بتهتم به دلوقتي فده هو طوق النجاه لك
واخد بال سيادتك ويخليك لك قيمه سياسيه
وتبقى لاعب مؤثر في كل مشاكل العالم
والمنطقه فيجب الاهتمام
و يعني الناس اللي يتولوا على مستوى عالمي
وليست يعني امكانياتهم
محدوده جزيل الشكر باشمهندس انا الحقيقه
مهتم جدا طبعا ان انا اعرف اكثر عن مشروع
محور قناه السويس والاسباب التي تعيقه لكن
عشان احنا لا نثقل على الناس استاذنك نرجئ
لحلقه اخرى نناقش فيه مشروع محور قناه
السويس باذن الله شكرا جزيلا لحضرتك وشكرا
لحضراتكم ونلقاكم في حلقات اخرى باذن الله